hallo liebe leute wir sind wieder
janisch und kari aus berlin für euch mit
easy firmen heute janus war heute beim
friseur
aber gestern war er auf der straße hier
in berlin und hat neue fragen gestellt
ihr wisst ja hanisch ist brasilien er
sie für den philosophischen teil der
sendung zuständig und so hat er auch
gestern auf der straße wieder eine eher
philosophische frage stellt janisch mehr
gab es diesmal was gab es für eine frage
was passiert mit dir wenn du tot bist
was passiert nach dem tod eine sehr
emotionale frage
eine interessante frage eine
philosophische und auch ein bisschen
religiöse fragen
wir sind gespannt ich bin gespannt auf
die antwort von janisch da schauen wir
jetzt mal rein
los geht's
ein termin ganz schnell wir helfen
menschen die deutsch sprechen ja aber
diesmal ist die frage sollte schon
ziemlich skurril ja was glaubst du was
passiert mit dir wenn du tot bist ja wie
sieht die zwischenwelt aus energie
einfach viel energie weiß ich nicht
unterschreiben
bist du dann zu ende da kommst du
irgendwann wieder ich glaube nicht dass
ich wiederkomme ich glaube das auch
nicht
dann genießt umso mehr das leben jetzt
hier und jetzt sag ich was mit mir
passiert
das ist irgendwo irgendwie weitergeht
keine ahnung vielleicht werde ich weiß
es nicht
ja kann sein oder vielleicht komme ich
nehme ich weiß ja nicht dass er keine
quatsch frage dass er eine sehr ähnlich
ist es mit quatsch frage wie wir würde
sowas fragen viele fragen so was wo
kommen wir her und was passiert was
passiert was glaubst du passiert mit
ihren tot bist
das weiß ich nicht glaube ich an gar
nichts ich hör auf zu existieren und das
ist gut so ich weiß es auch nicht genau
als ich habe nicht darüber nachgedacht
eigentlich wir haben ja ich denke lieber
noch ans leben ja ich glaub ich lebe
noch mal irgendwie und irgendwann
hoffentlich in eine bessere welt
das wünsche ich uns allen danke sehr
nichts also ich bin dann einfach tot
das ist die form stone nichts und lässt
uns nicht immer aber widerspricht das
nicht einen logischen gefühl nichts gibt
es einige
doch finde ich schon also nichts geben
was glauben sie was passiert mit ihnen
wenn sie tot sind was mit mir passiert
ich hoffe dass ein gütiger vater im
himmel mein leben nicht ganz beendet das
ein geistiges leben beginnt ich hoffe
ich bin nicht sehr religiös aber ich
denke alles was mein gutes getan hat im
leben
das wird einem vergütet es geht mir
jetzt so weil ich sehr alt bin und ich
erfahre sehr viel freundlichkeit
ich schätze ich werde vielleicht für
manche generation vergessen sein
was glauben sie passiert mit ihnen wenn
sie irgendwann tot sind
dann lebe ich erst richtig hauen wir
erstmal richtig
nein das mache ich sicher nicht aber ich
habe frieden und genieße frieden
ich glaube
bin dann einfach weg mein körper ist
unter der erde und das war was ich was
passiert wenn ich tot bin dann passiert
gar nicht sein bier dann werde ich zu
staub und alles ist gut
die energie zwischen den kohlenstoff
verbindungen in meinem körper wird ein
eingehen in das universum und neues
leben wird daraus entstehen
ich glaube dass man die energie von
einem selber irgendwie vielleicht mit
den anderen energien zusammenstürzt in
der luft und ja dass man hoffentlich
endlich mal glücklich wird und zur ruhe
kommen
ich glaub entweder wird man wieder
geworden oder man kommt und wohin wo es
schön ist oder irgendwie anders oder man
also ich glaube ihnen die wiedergeburt
dass man dann was anderes vielleicht ein
insekt oder am baum oder man kommt in
den himmel sich das verdient oder die
hölle so ganz ähnlich denke ich auch
dass das muss doch einen sinn machen
das leben muss doch wenn die seele des
menschen
das kann doch nicht einfach aufhören
wird es auch nicht also ja wenn ich tot
bin werde ich erst mal hoffentlich
in den himmel kommen und
mit ganz viele philosophen und dichter
sprechen können und ganz viel spaß haben
vielleicht eine große party wir werden
auf jeden fall wieder zu einer materie
die sich dann wieder weiter entwickelt
und sie bestehen alle außer tun
wir bestehen vor allen dingen aus dem
intellekt wir bestehen freundlich meine
aus dem segment chemisch zusammen
die ganze sind das atom es ist ein
logisches während es kann auch sein dass
das was die sozusagen sehen nur ein ganz
kleiner teil ist und wenn wir sterben
dann erweitert es uns ins größere
sozusagen
was glauben sie was passiert mit ihnen
wenn sie tot sind
geht es weiter was mir mehr weiß ich
nicht ich weiß nur dass wir dann das ist
dann weitergeht
also für die die können kirche und der
mensch ist etwas anderes jeder muss
seine eigene selbstfindung erreichen
ja und dann geht er den richtigen weg
was glaubst du was glaubst du was
passiert mit dir wenn du tot bist ich
denke ich verschwinde ich glaube nicht
an ein leben nach dem tod
ich denke wenn man tot das ist mir
einfach weg keine ahnung nicht also been
weg.de mehr kann ich dazu auch nicht
sein
dann haben sie alles gesagt danke gar
nichts ich werde verbrannt und dann
passt es ja das war unser material für
heute ja nicht interessieren würde was
haben die leute beantwortet es war ganz
deutlich
drei generationen die teenager die die
kiddies haben sich verschiedene märchen
ausgedacht solche gegen den himmel oder
ich werde zum engel die erwachsenen die
in der mitte des lebens stehen die
sagten gar nichts wir verschieben wir
gehen einfach und die älteren leuten
sind dann ausgesprochen religiöse also
die alten leute die haben gesagt ja der
liebe der vater ich hoffe dass der
liebenden vater mich annimmt
was glaubst du denn was passiert nach
dem tod ja ich glaube ganz
ganz entschieden und ganz stark daran
dass sie wiedergeboren werden und das
kommt aber etwas ist
nein eben nicht nicht buddhistische
hinduistische ich werde nicht als ein
baum oder ein insekt wiedergeboren
sondern auch nicht sondern ich denke
dass meine dass der tod dass das nichts
davor dass nichts danach nicht ein
inhalt meines bewusstsein ist also das
was ich kenne ist einzig und alleine das
leben um die einzige frage die ich kraft
des glaubens entscheide ist passiert das
nur einmal oder passiert es immer wieder
und ich entscheide mich für das immer
wieder dass klar das kommt mir
wahrscheinlich hervor als nur einmal
ungefähr vorstellen was für interessante
konversationen wir abends so am
küchentisch haben zum abschluss möchten
wir noch herzlich danken der heute vor
der kamera stand weil sie die chance
jetzt ein video von mir
halo hat danke dass du dabei was hat es
auch noch ein paar wochen in berlin
vielleicht auch noch länger und wenn ihr
mal ein video machen wollte hatte es ein
sehr professioneller kameramann aus
tunesien und ihr könnt ihn gerne auch
mal anheuern für euer video projekt
finden möchte zu einem schuss bedanken
wir uns dank janisch und wir möchten uns
besonders bedanken bei unseren fans ihr
seid dafür zuständig und helft uns dabei
dass wir im monat unsere miete hier in
berlin zahlen können und unser equipment
unserer software zahlen
das ist eine große hilfe von uns wir
werden bald ein paar neue sachen auf
bachelor haben und wir wünschen euch
ganz herzlich einladen mitglied zu
werden
hiermit wie seit bei easyjet bekommt sie
viele extras zum beispiel zu dieser
episode die mp4 dateien mit und ohne
untertitel mit denen ihr auch vorstellen
könnt die transkripte demnächst auch
grammatik übungen alles mit wie guck mal
rein bei patchen nicht da unten da unten
bei katrin werdet mitglied bei ysl
german danke fürs zuschauen bis zur
nächsten woche